rivers of mud sweeping through villages
in the west of Kenya in their path homes
marketplaces at police station and
schools in West pocket days of heavy
rains workers pull survivors from the
debris left behind many areas are still
waiting for official rescue teams to
arrive we ran to the other side of the
ridge and that's when we saw the flood
waters it came down in a big wave and
destroyed this whole shopping center and
carried away all the animals and two
cars most routes have been cut off and
bridges washed away locals say they've
had to carry flood victims to nearby
health centers on their backs this used
to be a big market but now it looks like
a river there were many shops here
before yesterday this was a vibrant
shopping centre but everything is gone
now everything has been swept away and
it's very distressing the government and
all relevant agencies need to come here
and as we speak several people are still
missing
Kenya's Red Cross warns that once the
flood waters clear others threats loom
they fear waterborne diseases and a
possible increase in coronavirus
infections in November al-jazeera filmed
Tam kal village in western pocket after
days of torrential rain flooding and
landslides entire families here were
killed communities surrounded by
floodwaters and isolated days later
families went out in search of their
relatives bodies many say it was the
worst disaster that they'd seen in a
lifetime
researchers say warming oceans are
causing unpredictable weather patterns
in eastern Africa and with more rain
expected in the coming days help may be
slow coming to these villages and the
problems may not be over nor about a
manly al-jazeera